[Music]
hello my name is tangem debonair i am a
member of parliament um i am the member
of parliament for bristol west i also
have the very strange
role of being called something called
the shadow leader of the house of
commons in shorthand terms that means
that when jacob rees-mogg stands up i
stand up on the other side
i wanted to talk about um the route into
feminist politics and then on to
political feminism and whatever that is
i'm going to give you a few examples we
can then pick them apart
i started this outline months ago months
and months and months ago and i planned
a nice little whistle stop tour around
the history of parliamentary feminism
and then everything sort of changed in
august
um because
the consequences of being a woman mp of
being a feminist ally in parliament felt
very very different when the fall of a
full of kabul in particular but the fall
of afghanistan happened
i've been in touch with a lot of
colleagues and i call them colleagues
with purpose so members of parliament of
the uh members of parliament in
afghanistan who are now dispersed some
of them are on the run some of them are
in disguise some of them are in hiding
most of them either they or their
families have been threatened with um
physical violence torture death
and
they're in a lot of difficulty
it would be easy for me to despair a
moment i am just slightly on the edge of
despair because i'm trying to help
people to get to safety and it's proving
incredibly difficult
i could talk more about what i think the
government has our government has done
to make it more difficult if you want
i'm going to try and park that for the
moment otherwise
it will be a bad start to this this this
talk um but my previous work with
violent men
i learned that the best predictor of
future risk of violence was past
behavior and i was speaking very
specifically about men whose ideology is
about violence and whose beliefs are
about women being lesser and so although
i know there were people who around the
fall of kabul thought maybe this is
taliban 2.0 i never did and so in fact
we
find it is
and as a feminist mp what i wanted to do
was to try and get
everything i could
focused on women in afghanistan who had
given up in many cases every semblance
of freedom and safety and their families
freedom and safety to try and make for
their country a better world and i felt
that one of the things that really
annoyed me was some of the ideology was
that we had somehow imposed on
afghanistan and on afghan women in
particular a very western notion of
equality which i felt really ignored the
history of afghanistan and afghanistan
afghan women's campaigning
and take a look at it sometimes if you
want to know more about what i'm talking
about but it also
ignored the fact that they'd created
their own democracy no matter how
imperfect and it was
all democracies are it had been built
for afghanistan it had been constructed
by afghans i have read the standing
orders which is now a bit of a joke but
i have read the afghan parliament
standing orders and they're not ours
it's a very different way of doing
things
and
it upset me that i thought there are
women particularly but also men involved
in afghan politics and campaigning for
social change
whose lives are now at serious risk
and we have an ideology which does not
serve the afghan people that i've spoken
to certainly
and which we seem to be relatively
powerless to stop
and as an actor because i consider
myself an actor not a commentator i'm a
parliamentarian i'm supposed to be an
actor so to be not just an activist i'm
supposed to be an actor
that's very very difficult to take
but i'm going to go back to where i
wanted to start which was in 1916
a group of women from the co-operative
women's guild were in parliament
and they were in parliament because they
had successfully lobbied for an
amendment to a social security bill it's
called something slightly different to
give women for the first time a single
maternity payment to be paid to them
and they were sat in what i think was
committee room 14 a room i know very
well and that they're at the back
because they are spectators not actors
so they're not allowed to speak and what
they saw was of those men of course they
were all men at that point who were
speaking the men who spoke against a
maternity payment being paid to women
were their labour colleagues
and
that
inspired them and i consider myself part
of that tradition my grandmother was
very much part of that tradition of
co-op women's guilders
they said well up with this we cannot
put if we can't be
if we can't influence change enough by
being
spectators and campaigners we have to be
actors we have to be in the room not
looking at the room so some of them then
in fact did stand for parliament and as
i'm very fond of saying i don't think
there's any reason not to admit this to
you all i've said this many times to my
colleagues in the labour party it's 105
years on and i'm still occasionally
having to say to you guys stop telling
me we'll get round to women's equality
stop telling me that because that's what
those women face there were eight of
them who were elected in 1924 and they
were stunning women
and they with one exception maybe very
just didn't really ever make it to the
prominence that their talent and skill
and determination deserved they were
constantly told get you we'll get around
to it we'll get round to it
and i first got um i pet beared my own
witness to this when i was a young
feminist working at women's aid national
office trying to lobby for changes to
protect victims of domestic violence i
sat in um if you've ever been in
parliament there's a sort of raked
audience bit at the top i sat there
those days there wasn't a screen
and i watched
paul broughting now lord watling at the
dispatch box that i now get to stand up
every week and feel slightly awed by
saying things that i'd written i mean
we'd given him lines but he was the one
who got to decide whether or not that
that amendment got pushed whether that
law got through and that also inspired
me it sort of lodged in the back of my
brain also something weird happened that
night lord russell who'd been working
with us in the house of lords took me
and my colleague nicholas about three
o'clock in the morning when the bill
ended took us to tea in what i now
realized was the house of commons cafe
cafeteria when we came back through
central lobby i heard and saw what i
swear with shirley bassey singing
goldfinger i'll never know for sure
because i've asked loads of people were
you there do you remember
um
and now fast forward and i'm learning
how to take my feminism into parliament
i'm still learning i've been an mp for
six years i'm still learning because i
spent the intervening time in in
professional feminism in feminist
activism mostly working in violence
against women and girls
latterly for 10 years working with
violent men actually and that was a very
interesting way of doing what i always
thought of a sharp end
front edge feminism because you've got
misogyny right there in front of you in
the room
usually that meant being in there on a
monday night with 16
very violent men uh with a co-gendered
uh co-facilitator so it was always one
man one woman so one of the things we
were doing and we had to work on this
was how do you represent gender equality
between a man and a woman what does that
mean
what gift is it and we did see it as a
gift that you are giving to men in the
room many of whom had never seen that
in their own lives what does it look
like so it looked like lots of things it
looked like
him being able to cope if we disagreed
and not get threatening or
violent
me being able to be heard
him getting that i had as much right as
him to be heard but him also getting
that
a lot of the work was his and the men's
to fix it wasn't my job as the woman in
the room to fix their sexually abusive
behavior so that meant we had a
pre-agreement in certain parts of these
32 weeks that he would lead some things
because it was important that it was a
man showing the men this is our problem
to fix but also that when i wanted to i
could say hang on a minute that's not
quite how we see it or how i see it or
how other women have told me they see it
even if i didn't so i've tried to take
this into politics
and i think it's got parallels of being
a feminist researcher as well as a
feminist activist so what questions are
you asking who are you asking them of
who are you listening to what is your
intellectual framework
through what
civ of analysis of your data
are you working
who are you listening to who are you
shutting up who are you silencing
and part of that i think is about the
processes of who you talk to as an mp
who do who do you whose voice do you let
into the room whose voice do you shut
out because if you see a panel on any
given topic let's say it's tech let's
say it's science and all you see are men
or you see that it's a panel on politics
and all you see are men you reinforce
your idea of who is to be a scientist a
tech specialist and a politician and
it's frankly no longer good enough just
to say oh it's so hard to get a woman
who's expert on this no it isn't
so i made a hard and fast rule and i've
stuck to it including rather awkwardly
when a lovely lot of volunteers at a
library were doing a sort of we were
doing a what's your favorite book and i
looked at the program and said well six
men one woman i'm not doing it and they
said we're just volunteers what are we
supposed to do there's not many women in
politics and it was you know it was a
what's your favorite book as a
politician
and i think that there are actually
plenty just make more effort i'm only
the 408th woman ever to have been
elected to parliament 408. just bear in
mind there are 650 each parliament
when i was elected there were more men
in the room than had ever been elected
the number that had ever been elected as
women okay so that's
terrible that's centuries where we were
not visible we were not heard we were
not present why does that matter what
gets left out i tell you lots of things
get left out when there's no woman in
the room to say hang on what about this
hang on what about that and they're
often not
things that some people call women's
issues but they are things that we tend
to spot without stereotyping my own sex
too much
there is just something that happens
when there are literally no women in the
room there's also something by the way
that happens when there is no diversity
or another
spectrum as well and so that's one of
the things we do i think we also need to
amplify each other's voices even when we
disagree i have a principle when i'm
chairing that i i warn you now always
take the first question from a woman
it's not because i think we're less
confident it's just that i have noticed
from bitter experience if i take the
first question from a man that somehow
seems to be a sort of unwritten tone now
we're going to be fine by the way men
please ask questions i'd rather you did
or make points but i will be taking the
first point from a woman so bear that in
mind
um i mentioned modelling gender equality
with men in parliament when i first
arrived
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas